présentement nous sommes prendrait 1h30
au lieu de 30 minutes en voiture
Juliette habite à Montréal est elle doit
traverser en voiture de 4 à 6 fois
semaine le pont Louis Hippolyte la
fontaine pour se rendre sur son lieu de
travail à Brossard la fermeture
partielle du pont l'oblige à changer
d'itinéraire l'autobus 189 au coin de la
rue ensuite le métro jusqu'à berrucam
ensuite
la ligne orange jusqu'à bonne aventure
et ensuite l'autobus j'ai vraiment peur
j'en ai pas d'alternative vraiment
j'aimerais ça la prendre le transport en
commun mais il y en a c'est pas efficace
pour dédommager les automobilistes le
ministère des Transports a mis à leur
disposition des voies réservées pour les
autobus taxi et covoiturage 5
stationnements incitatifs gratuits des
navettes d'autobus des lignes d'autobus
de la Rive-Sud au métro Longueuil et une
rame de métro supplémentaire sur la
ligne jaune
et pour que la grande majorité des
usagers délaissent l'auto-solo l'offre
de services doit être concurrentielle
selon la professeure Catherine Morency
faut offrir des services les plus
directs possibles qui ne sont pas pris
dans la congestion qui vont nous
permettre d'accéder rapidement à nos
destinations et à plusieurs heures pour
l'instant les trois années d'entrave au
pontiné Louis de La Fontaine inquiète
dans les résidents de la Rive-Sud que
ceux de l'île de Montréal c'est déjà
assez pénible ça va encore être plus
pénible qu'avant ça va changer
complètement mon horaire que je quitte
vers 4h le matin pour venir travailler
doute que l'augmentation du trafic vers
le pont Jacques-Cartier ça va amener
beaucoup de trafic sur les rues
résidentielles en attendant Julia petiat
réfléchit sur les différents trajets
qu'elles devront emprunter à compter du
mois de novembre mais encore là pas
question de déménager ni de changer
d'emploi ça fait 15 ans que je travaille
là donc ça me tente pas de changer ici
Gabriel prout Radio-Canada Montréal